we were in constant contact though all
weekend i think people are probably
gonna see you on your phone a lot and
think you're just like texting
like your friends or something but we
were texting the entire time on the show
and i don't know if you know people are
gonna know that or not so i wanted to
say that but did i help you or hurt you
by doing that
oh god i you helped me so much and for
reference for everyone listening like
kelly called me at 7 00 pm nashville
time
and they were shooting the next day at
1pm
in la and um and so i i fully went back
to college like on the flight over she
sent me all the blind auditions she sent
me
everything about like everyone on her
team what she loved what she was looking
for and so as soon as i landed
you and i got to talk and you just like
downloaded all of your incredible
knowledge and you were like this is what
i love about this person this is what i
want to see
and so when i got in the chair i was
like first of all where's that seat
warmer that you were telling me about
because it is cold
i told you i was like look for the seat
warmer your butt is going to be so cold
and i wear spanx girl i'm all covered up
and i understand it's you i'm cold
you had to be dying but can you can you
tell everyone
like about this week's episode because i
wasn't there so you would know
honestly it's so crazy because obviously
there's great talent on a show called
the boys like the voices are crazy but
when you're actually sitting there in
the room and you're watching
these these artists some of them are
like really seasoned and some of them
are
really early on and like discovering
their instrument
you're watching them just i just had
goosebumps most of the time just the
talent is really crazy this season
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool
i'm just saying no pressure